[Music]
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be
interviewing a serviced accommodation
expert in the berkshire area just
outside of london
this guy is making very very good money
doing the rent-to-service accommodation
strategy but he also manages properties
on service accommodation so we're gonna
be talking about all the nitty-gritty
stuff that we do not usually talk about
on youtube so i hope you enjoy this
video if you're thinking of getting into
service accommodation i think you're
going to find a lot of inspiration but
also information from alexandra in this
interview so alexander welcome to
winners on a wednesday how are you doing
i'm really well thank you for having me
so you've built to a really nice little
portfolio around berkshire buckingham
shear you've got all these different
properties in these different areas and
you've been doing this now for a couple
of years so firstly in your words what
is serviced accommodation
service accommodation is where you take
an apartment or a house um you can
either rent it off a landlord or if
you've if you're owning the property
then you can also do this as well
obviously of course with the right
education
and you're gonna be offering it as a
short stay so instead of a normal
tenancy of six months or a year you're
offering it to people for a couple of
nights or a couple of weeks or a couple
of months at a time so basically what
you're saying is instead of renting a
property out to a family or just on a
normal long-term let you're renting it
out to people on a short stay agreement
which presumably is going to be a lot
more work potentially for the owner
definitely yeah there's definitely more
involved in it we've actually seen you
know i did the business model originally
on people staying for two to sort of
five nights yeah but actually we found
people staying up to you know a couple
of weeks or even a couple months at a
time but of course you are offering a
furnished property with all builds
included and there is an extra level of
service there that people do expect now
the really interesting thing is in my
opinion
if you attempt to do this and you don't
really know what you're doing you
haven't had the training or you haven't
got the power team you haven't got the
management in place this can be a
logistical nightmare with the linen and
the bookings and double bookings and
reviews can be really hard but
if you get a good power tier in place
and if you know what you're doing and
you learn the skills which is what we're
going to be showing in this video then
it's a dream so what's the upside to
serviced accommodation the upside is
you've got a business which you can
scale which you can systemize and that
ultimately can give you that time
freedom that we'll talk about financials
looking good but it's a time frame
that's really key and it's kind of the
days where i've got i've got a team
member who deals with our guests i've
got systems involved that automate a lot
of the processes that means that you
know recently i've actually been able to
have a weekend which has been quite nice
and you know the business has still been
running in the background people have
still been staying in our properties
and we've had our cleaning team keeping
on top of the linen and the cleaning and
making sure that the properties are kept
at really high standard we've had our
sort of guest management team making
sure the guests are happy how many
properties did you have
so live and active now i think it's 12
it should be 13 by the end of the week
13 by the end of the week so it's quite
a nice little sized portfolio now
the thing is this alexander if you buy a
house and rent it out you're probably
going to be making the average rent for
about 8 900 a month take away your
mortgage payments take away your
management and all the different
expenses maintenance to go with it
you'll probably get enough of a profit
of about 300 quid yeah now
your properties don't earn you 300
pounds they own you far far more than
that right yeah correct so
if you're going to have little
properties buy to let houses that are
making you 200 300 400 quid here and
there you need to have a large portfolio
to to to be making some decent profit
also tax implications the section 21
there's a lot of things you can't claim
mortgage back unless it's through a
business
service accommodation that doesn't apply
you need a lot of money to get started
how much money did you have
you've been going now a couple of years
you're going strong you're making a good
profit which we'll get into but how much
money did you have when you got started
in the property business me personally i
started with xero i had um i managed to
get borrow a bit of money from mum and
dad to help me come on on the course
right um i wouldn't necessarily advise
that to everyone else but that i really
was the cause or borrowing it from mom
and dad wouldn't necessarily advise
borrowing money to do the course but um
i'd say you know for me i'd set my heart
on doing the property business and i
knew that that's what i wanted that's
the path i wanted to go down
um but yeah started with no money to
actually put down on property but
through networking which was massively
encouraged during the the academy events
which was awesome um i met a whole load
of people and sort of put that vibe out
there that i just wanted to chat to as
many people as possible yeah and through
that i met a business partner who i
actually spoke to him about how a one
academy member who i'd been dealing with
had you know said he had some money to
help me start off with the first unit
and that academy member had gone up to
liverpool and instead of picking up one
deal picked up six and it come back to
me gone really sorry alex haven't got
any cash anymore so i was kind of
twiddling my thumbs and just kept on
networking with people and meeting
people either for a coffee or for a
drink yeah and i just checked this guy
explaining my story and he just turned
around and went oh yeah if you want if
you want you know some money to put
towards your business and i can help out
i was like all right i wasn't expecting
i wasn't even pitching i was just
sharing the story right
i'm just explaining to him you know why
i thought the business model would work
the research i've done into it and the
plans i had
and so yeah we got started off from
there but the thing is there are a lot
of entrepreneurs out there that are
actively looking for people that they
can invest money into absolutely and
i've even had people in sort of i've got
quite a few different networking groups
and mentoring groups now that i belong
to and i've had people reach out in the
last few weeks just say alex i've got
this lump of money in the bank uh it's
not doing very it's not doing any good
in the bank i want to put into property
can you i'm time poor but i'm cash rich
right can you help me go and look for
them so the key is then because a lot of
people think they might not have a lot
of money and they think oh well i can't
do anything but actually if you haven't
got a lot of money you need to get the
skills
and the network and the and the team
around you to be able to start making
money it's just blowing my mind how much
uh cash especially after chronovirus is
available in the market you know we've
got people with bounce back loans we've
got people with inherited money or money
they've worked for money they haven't
spent on holidays in the last couple of
years there's literally hundreds of
thousands if not millions all around the
country all you need to do is just put
yourself in the right environment yeah
to meet those people here's why i call
you a service accommodation expert
because not only are you making money
now which is great and we'll get onto
the figures hopefully you'll be able to
share a little bit about how much you're
making i know i know it's um a lot
but you
made it through the lockdown as well so
your business ha as almost like
recession proof i mean damn
if you can make money when you're not
allowed to leave the house
you're not allowed to book a hotel
all the hotels are closed down
and you're able to make business through
this mod
money through this model admittedly not
as much as you are now but you got
through that whole period i know we
spoke a lot
and and you worked really hard you put
systems in place um
now you're making crazy money but i feel
like you've got so many properties now
you've got 12 you're moving on to 13 14
properties
making very good money i think it's fair
to say that you've been in the game long
enough for me to be able to say because
if i want help i mean i know i was
having a property recently um you know
in your kind of area i'm like i wonder
how that's gonna do i'll pick up the
phone speak to you so i figured let me
introduce you to my audience um because
i think that you've got a lot of you've
learned a lot you've grown a lot you've
got a lot of good content and
information in your head i wanted to
kind of draw that out of you in this
interview so when you're going and
getting a rent to rent okay
how do you know because this is one of
the biggest issues that i think people
have in this business of service
accommodation if you're buying a house
to rent it out you just speak to a
letting agent and the letter manager
will say it will rent for 900 quid great
you know if you're doing a hmo you speak
to a hmo management company and you go
hey how much would these rooms run out
for oh they went out for 400 pounds each
and you've got four there's five it's
two grand a month right i know how much
rent i'm gonna get
when you're taking on whether you're
buying whether you're controlling when
you take on a unit and the intention is
to rent it out on short stays
number one who the heck's gonna rent it
who's your market number two how much
are you expecting to make is it a stab
in the dark is there a formula to wear
that out
help me out here alexander yeah
certainly so first of all it's about
doing the market research so we're
looking at airbnb booking.com that is
just the tip of the iceberg and
obviously in corona various times those
the calendars were shut on both those
platforms right so you can't rely on any
one platform to get your bookings from
so you've got to think about this as you
always say as a business you know it's
not just a one trick pony you've got to
have multiple streams of inquiries so
airbnb.com is for your basic research
you then want to be phoning up local
companies because we we're starting to
see corporate travel it's starting to
happen again now in the last couple of
weeks we've taken two one-month bookings
off one group who are working with a big
corporate company in our local area
which is fantastic now in terms of the
money we've been having some fantastic
rates during sort of august and septem
and the july period in the summer i've
been taking a sort of kind of review on
what we're going to do going forward but
it's roughly sort of 500 pounds a month
plus 100 pounds per room so if i've got
a two bed i would and this is profit by
the way if you've got two bed i want 500
plus the two rooms worth so it's about
700 pounds profit is what i should be
aiming for right even as we're coming
into the low season now okay and the
high seasons and again you need to look
at this a business you sometimes talk to
me about i made this much off this one
you say to me off the camera this one
made four grand in one month whatever
but it's like yeah that's fine that was
august or or whatever
you know now november sort of time um
the peak times you've got christmas
which is
crazy high all around december the
holidays you've got the the summer
holidays
during the summer maybe a little bit
easter during the kids are off school
it can go a little bit crazy
you've got to look at this over a whole
year though right absolutely you've got
to look at this yeah i mean the property
that sort of stunner little one that i
was talking about earlier on we managed
that for for one of our clients and um
they run a dental surgery and they've
got this little flat above they were
getting like a thousand pounds a month
on that flat as a normal rental right we
managed to give them some really crazy
numbers in august but obviously now what
we're going to get in the low season and
we've just taken a booking for
uh three months and that guest is gonna
be paying i think just under three
thousand a month right so you're paying
a grand a month
but your guest is paying you three grand
a month it's actually a managed property
so we're just doing charging a
management fee but the landlord uplift
they're getting on that is instead of a
ground a month they're getting over two
grand so it's 100 increase on the normal
rent and what are you taking 15 15
so some of your landlords say
we want you to just manage it yeah and
we'll
and we'll give you a percentage of the
profit we'll share the profits profit
share or percentage on return and then
some of them just say i want to know
what i'm going to get you give me a
guaranteed rent and then anything you
make on top you can keep for yourself
um okay
what kind of areas i know you've been
working in berkshire buckinghamshire
yeah lots of
hampshire lots of different villages
little small towns
what areas work best
i think you've got to look at the a
couple of key things one you've got to
work out is it a tourist area or is it a
kind of commuter and sort of corporate
area the areas i've been looking at are
kind of just outside of london so we do
get a bit of both we've got some lovely
countryside we've got lots of tourist
attractions but we've also got a lot of
traveling companies there's some big
companies in and around just outside
west london all alongside of the m4 and
the a4 corridor
so by doing the research on airbnb and
booking.com if you're on sort of you
know the coastal routes it's going to be
quite a touristy sort of atmosphere and
you've got to you know try and maximize
your rates in the summer season and the
high season but you've also got to sort
of try and work out a plan for
mitigating
the effects of the low season but if you
come sort of more inland around the
particularly sort of urban areas and
places that are just outside of the
inner city then you can find a lot of
places that will perform you know still
really well in the summer but will be
sort of more consistent there'll be less
of a downward trend going through the
winter periods okay so like november
coming into november
what kind of profit will you be
expecting because you can brave about
july or yeah or all you want but these
kind of quiet average average months
across your portfolio what kind of
profit including the properties that
you're controlling you're managing are
you making a month
a bit of a mixture but we're still
getting around seven eight hundred
pounds profit on the two beds right and
and more on the the three and the four
beds and you've got 12 in total 12 in
total yet so with your number 13 coming
on she had a message on the landlord
today he's just doing a few
uh touches up touch-ups on it and fixing
a few bits for us and uh so so you're
talking double digits profit per month
that's incredible and last time last
time you came on the channel
you were making like two grand just
barely yeah yeah 50 1500 1500 barely um
and you had like two or three two or
three units it's crazy we were i think
that first summer of course you know we
picked up a
unit two and three in summer just after
just after coronavirus and then we had a
guest in there i think one of them for
like you know a month and with you know
that we were making maybe yeah 300 quid
profit on that and you know roll on the
turnovers double the profits that kind
of double or triple that
crazy and so yeah just when the
floodgates opened of course the market
opened up again the summer was worked
out another thing is you were still
making profit through that lockdown we
were that's the key thing and you know
people we could only supply certain
markets so we had contractors who are
actually working in to refurb hospitals
right uh which is really interesting
market to be in we had other contractors
who were working on sort of the railway
lines who were then allowed to you know
outdoor work was allowed
and it's just a case of
whatever happens i was listening to an
audio book today actually by a guy up in
newcastle and um
he's a fitness trainer and he was just
saying how a lot of the guys he's been
training he particularly focuses on
men's health he says these guys you know
they're in really rough backgrounds they
had some addiction issues family issues
all sorts but he'd been working with
them so closely before coronavirus that
when coronavirus hit they were already
in like the educational and mental space
to make to improve their businesses and
adapt to the changing situation that's
what really occurred to me this morning
like there's always opportunities yeah
it doesn't matter where you are what the
economy is even even with growing advice
but literally the whole world shut down
there were still opportunities to to
give a good service and to also make
some you know some decent sort of money
on the bottom line as well really
interesting thing i believe and i know
you believe in business the way to make
money in business is to add value to
people right absolutely if you're trying
if you're trying to chase the money i
want money i want money i want money me
me me me me me then you're going to
struggle but if you think actually how
can i create a good product good service
how can i then learn to make it easy to
sell that product or service how can i
actually add value to people's lives
that's when you start getting rich
and with that being said
one of the things is sometimes i don't
understand you know people are doing
like foreign exchange and these
different things and i'm like that's
cool but i like to get satisfaction from
thinking who am i helping what value am
i adding so i'll ask you some questions
alexander number one
what value are you adding to the
landlords
when you offer them a guaranteed rent
and then you go make a load of profit
some people might think but why wouldn't
they just do it themselves why would
they give you their property for you
then to run it a service convention why
wouldn't they just hit themselves what
value are you adding to the landlords
that's the first question great question
i'm really glad you asked this because
we've made some mistakes and we've got
it wrong a couple of times where we were
trying to we're trying to grow the
business too quickly we were sort of we
had lots of contractors coming in who
needed accommodation and we were like
right let's the more properties we can
get bring on the more people we can
serve for sure we need to make some
profit if we can serve more people then
we can serve even more people as you
know it's that exponential effect we've
got it wrong a few times and that was
really unfortunate but we learned from
that how did you get it wrong
right basically we let the wrong type of
guests stay in the properties so you
just were chasing the money and just
thinking i'll just put anyone in because
i want to get the money it wasn't quite
as simple as that there was
you can sort of
run this business in several different
ways you can either have a couple of
individual points of contact whether
with individual contracts with companies
who only work with those companies or
you can open yourself up to the wider
market now coming out of chrome advice
we needed to open ourselves up to you
know any sort of good paying guest
because the supply of guests was limited
we wanted to see this business through
the summer where we knew we could keep
it expanded right so you're less choosy
with the with the guests exactly we were
just on the verge of bringing in a whole
load of procedures like id checks
security deposits t's and c's and
unfortunately some guests who didn't
behave themselves well and we had to
really take some lessons from that and i
it wasn't a case of that it's just yeah
they weren't very respectful to the
neighbors um they weren't you know
they're just bad guests bad guesses
maybe a party or whatever just not not a
good guess not not the guesswork
landlord getting upset coming down on
you and causing a problem with the
relationship is that because
you understandably because of the times
but you didn't vet the guests properly
not as well as we should how do you vet
the guests now we do an id check we do a
security deposit that's a refundable
deposit and we also get them to sign our
terms and conditions we also do a phone
call with them and then we also have
surveillance we have sort of cctv
surveillance in the properties and we
also have sort of sound monitoring now
that's really good sale now because if
i'm a landlord and you're saying i want
to take your property on my first
thought's gonna be if you've got people
coming in and out all the time what
happens if i have crazy guests and they
damage my property or they caused
problems with the my neighbors and i
started getting complaints i'm the
ultimate owner of the property but you
start talking like that saying we have
cctv we do these checks these it makes
me feel comfortable as the landlord but
my big question is i understand that you
might be able to look after the property
and everything but why wouldn't the
landlord just do it themselves why would
they pass you the property to manage it
and to run it a service accommodation
great question everyone's motivated by
different things some landlords like to
be actively involved and like to get
like to get their hands on we actually
work with some landlords who they really
like supporting our business model and
we like supporting their their
investments that they've made in these
assets and so they're happy to do the
maintenance and they charge that back to
us we're happy to work with them and
make sure that you know we're getting
guests in there who are going to you
know treat the property well yeah we've
also got other landlords who actually
it's an investment but they have too
busy doing their own they've got
full-time jobs so they want to put
someone in there where they're going to
say right i'd like someone to keep an
eye on it so yeah we've got our cleaners
going you know regularly to make sure
the property's been looked after we've
got maintenance team on board who will
but you're making per property you're
making between 500 and a thousand pounds
clean profit a month
if they're in a job and they're too busy
why wouldn't they just do it themselves
oh it's just a couple of key things is
if you don't know how you don't know
what you don't know bingo very true it
isn't easy to begin with absolutely
there's a lot of procedures and systems
and the key safe outside and getting
your channel manager all synced and
systemized there's a lot to it
it's probably about 100 processors that
kid you know 100 like bits of
information have to travel from one
place to another yeah to get every
single guest in right that's a mixture
of phone calls emails yeah sometimes
even text messages um all sorts of data
can you systemize it you can but is it
is that an overnight thing
it takes time it takes time takes
knowledge it takes it takes a mixture of
um education software automation and
experience absolutely
okay so the value to the landlord or the
owner is
i know what i'm doing i've got the
knowledge i can give you the guaranteed
rent or i can manage it and i'll just
take a percentage of the profits
that's the value to the landlord what
about the guests why would a guest pay
you
some of your guests stay in the property
for like two three months yeah quite
regularly yes yeah like that winchester
property how much that winter spot how
much how much how much we are you
getting on that turnover how much you
rent in that out for
a nightly rate no on a monthly average
our monthly average is about around
three thousand about three thousand and
how much are you paying the landlord so
we'll we take the 15 and then we'll give
the rest of the landlords so the
landlord's getting sort of 100 increase
in what they get on a normal long term
rent how much would you be would you be
able to rent that property for that just
as a standard single layer yeah about a
thousand pounds a month a thousand
pounds so why would why would someone
live in that property for three months
and pay nine grand
just for three months when they could
get somewhere with that same money they
could rent somewhere for nine months why
would they pay so much money great
question so
it's all about flexibility and ease of
access people you know when they come
with us they've got we have to do the
security checks etc but it's ultimately
it's a payment and it's an invoice and
then they're ready to go they don't have
to worry about bringing their furniture
they don't have to worry about putting
their names and bills um they can come
and stay and everything's ready to go
from day one so it's more like a hotel
yeah it's it's this interesting segment
in the market where people want they
want generally want more from hotels you
know they want to have a living space
rather than just the bedroom and being
sat on the edge of the bed watching tv
they want to have maybe a sort of a
dedicated kitchen area they want to cook
for themselves yeah people getting
really sort of health aware these days
so having that sort of
self-contained space they can come and
go as they please they've got all the
separate spaces they want
and they can cook themselves some food
as well and that's where the market's
changing
would you advise
people to get into the service
accommodation space would you say it's a
good a good thing to do
if you're passionate about giving a good
service and about making sure that
you're giving a great service to the
landlord but also a great service to the
guests and it's absolutely great great
business because that's another thing
it's like some people i had this
conversation with amelia um a couple
weeks ago
where she emilia was saying she's saying
this is quite hard like this is quite
difficult it's a lot of processes um
there's a lot to this and i was like
well yeah
and then she said to me she said
she said do you think that people
realize how hard this is and i said
things we've got to remember is it's
hard for you right now because you're
doing it for the very first time
when you learn to drive i remember when
i first drive and i was like man this is
hard you've got to change gear and look
in the window and it's really hard maybe
even on my driving test i was there and
i was like oh straight up right it's
hard yeah yeah but now i don't even
think about it now just
imagine if someone said i'll walk three
hours because i don't want to drive
because driving's too hard
you'd think they were crazy yeah and
it's the same i think with property
investment and being an entrepreneur is
it hard yeah does it take a lot of work
and learning new things it does
especially to begin with but once you
know how to do it and and you get it and
you've done it and you're trained then
it becomes easy i keep searching for
like well you know where is the easy
option it just just doesn't exist what
you can do is you can make the most of
the tools and resources you've got like
the internet
the videos you put out and a lot of
people put out on how to make money in
property you know the education you can
get is just so accessible but it's just
unreal we've never had this in history
and it's there's opportunities and
properties there's opportunities in
numerous different business industries
across the across the spectrum
and i think that's just really important
people to remember is that it's still
tough there's still lessons to be
learned but if you're not learning
lessons you're not growing and for me i
think to feel alive i need to feel like
i'm learning stuff every day um you know
we have the business has challenges
there
every day we're learning from our guests
we're talking to the landlords we're
learning how can we be better how can we
give better service how we can look
after the properties better how we can
do everything better yeah and i really
enjoy that learning process and the
thing is you get paid handsomely now
because you offer value to people you'll
provide to the landlords value to the
guests you've got good systems in place
and that's where getting paid well you
become a more valuable person you know
um what happened tell me tell me what
happened when you got the phone call
from emilia last week what happened oh
my gosh yeah yeah yeah so um
so it was from your perspective because
it'd be interesting
yeah yeah absolutely so it's really
funny because we had an inquiry come
from one of our online platforms i
handed it over to my colleague to sort
of deal with this lovely lovely lady
called emilia who wants to offer a
guaranteed rent for um
six months or a couple of maybe a year
or so yeah and um i was like oh i think
i know what's going on here i think this
is someone else who wants to start a
service accommodation business in the
area
and uh that's your assistant that told
you that and so i think i think millie
and i had a phone call right because my
assistant said this is what she wants to
do and i gave her a phone call back you
rang amelia i rang amelia right and did
you know that amelia was linked to me no
idea at that point no i know i just
thought maybe it sounds like another one
i didn't know either in fact i didn't
even i didn't say to amelia oh call
about this amelia
found you
her own because i told her i told her
doing every single person from open rent
and gum treats
so so she's she rings you up
funny because it wasn't it was actually
a property that we were managing not
even one that i was renting sort of my
in my own personal portfolio so it was
funny the way it came through that way
and then yeah all of a sudden i just
said yeah well i'm in windsor i do this
as well and i think the cogs in your
head were wearing going hang on this is
if someone else is in windsor and
they're saying oh i do this as well they
must be my student
all right that must be so when you're
saying when you i don't know who you
were yeah she's sounding a bit different
on the phone so you're chatting with i'm
driving this is the conversation and and
i heard you say oh well we actually do
something similar and i'm thinking
who's this dude and i said i don't know
who's this dude and i think i might say
it's alex i'm like and then i took over
the phone i'm like
alexander price is it you oh my goodness
he's like but it's just crazy it's such
a small world when you're in the problem
everyone knows everyone and i think
that's why it's so important to maintain
a really good reputation because this is
a small world yep you know a super super
small world and then we met up and
obviously what did you think of amelia's
property oh that was awesome yeah i had
a quick look at it and um saw the saw
some of the pictures and saw the
location and i thought that's a real
cracking deal she's got herself there
very very very beautiful deal let's go
everywhere she just had a 23 night
booking on that really yeah 23 night
booking on that it's good it's full
it's full so that's incredible next next
steps for you alexander uh are you gonna
are you gonna start um doing biofilms
your finances building your own
portfolio or are you just
scale in this what are you going to do
so i've been thinking about over the
last few months like where do i want to
take the business next yeah um we found
that we've we had a fantastic summer but
we really need to sort of kind of make
ourselves you know strong and as secure
as possible yeah so actually sort of
doubling down on all the systems we want
to get ready for a big expansion in new
year but right now we're focusing on all
the systems we're already picking up
properties kind of on a monthly basis
anyway because i've sort of just kind of
shared the message so much and spoke to
so many people we've got landlords who
are actually buying property now to then
give to us which is really brilliant as
well look right there but we're scott
landers are working with who you know
potentially giving us first dibs on
properties that they they purchased to
say alex would this work for you and
your business model so when we built
those relationships right okay we are
doing something right here and just
making sure we build on those going
forward get the systems right and get
ready for some big expansion in new york
nice are you moving into new areas
um not right now we might do are you
working in beckham's field not yet would
you like to certainly be interested i've
got a property mechanism
definitely do something um okay so when
we spoke about a year ago i think it was
almost exactly a year ago actually um
when you came in for your first winners
wednesday interview you'd gone through
the academy you just about become
financially free but it was early and i
think i wanted i like bringing people
back on as part two because sometimes
people might wonder where are they now
yeah all these people that come with us
on a wednesday and say i'm financially
free like well where are they a year
later or two years later now it's been
two years since you're on the academy um
what would you say you sort of your
biggest takeaway has been over the last
couple of years
that's a great question i think i was
even thinking about this earlier on
today for okay i thought what has been
the big learning curve it's just
i think you know through people i sound
a bit cheesy but through people there
are possibilities yeah i think that's
just the biggest thing like i met you
know especially
like the one thing i remember vividly
from the academy was just the speed
networking i was just like wow then the
space of like 15 20 minutes i met like
five to ten people who kind of we'd
already roughly knew about each other
because we've been in the same room we
got a chance to exchange numbers and
exchange you know i'm looking for i'm
looking to help you know build a
portfolio that okay i've got i've got
money but i don't have time and suddenly
making those connections was really
powerful and that's what's really helped
me start this business that's what's
helped me expand the business
um and it's yeah for me it's just case
of you know we we're trying to try and
give a great product we try and
communicate with our guests and the
landlords as much as possible and i'm
always learning from the people that i'm
speaking with and i'm learning from my
my various mentors and the various
people i have my network so yeah just
the people is what makes it possible so
so true i think your environment is is
everything and
it's all about who you know it's not not
just what you know it's who you know i
love what you said when i came on the
first winners on a wednesday because you
said uh you know i was talking about
sort of my previous experiences with my
family and the recession of 2007 2008
and you said oh you know dude you're
like you're you were in that recession
that that recession was your world it
was the outside world but it was also
your world whereas what that recession
wasn't the world for other people you
know they'd create their own environment
they create their own mindset and i
especially felt that with this with this
lockdown um you know when the first
lockdown came in i wasn't quite sure and
i just got my first unit live in march
last year in 2020
but we came through that we expanded
some more again i was a bit tentative
but then come at the back end of 2020 i
was like right this is going to work
i've got confidence i spoke to a lot of
mentors and people i said right what
should i do and i said yep go for it
trust me this will pay dividends
and we and we expanded um we managed to
get on board amazing
properties and we've been to each other
sometimes walking around the past yeah
absolutely you know i'm like alex
what are you doing what more deals you
got you point over the river that's the
latest deal it's great to be neighbours
where we bumped into each other i was
actually offered one of the properties
literally on that um
on that riverside incredible literally a
hundred meters away incredible that one
couldn't come together you talk as well
you talk a lot about um mentors and
education and you mentioned that a few
times how important that is definitely
you know a lot of people try not to pay
for education and my my i'll say this
i'll say you've got to pay for either
education
or mistakes yep or the third thing you
have to pay for which is loss of income
because you just don't do anything yeah
you you can't go around your whole life
saying i want i i want all of the upside
but not the downside i want to know
everything i make lots of money but i
don't want to invest in myself i don't
want it it's like you have to choose
which heart and again going back to is
this easier is it hard everything's hard
yeah being overweight
is hard but so is being slim
yeah
working in a job is hard but says having
a business being rich is hard and so
being poor everything's hard it's about
what hardship you want to choose
and i think that's what i like is when
you it's having choices and i think when
i said look now and i think you know
you know i had a phone call from amelia
earlier on and he said you know right
you're free for an interview today i'm
like okay i'll rearrange my diary let's
do it yeah and thanks and that's because
i'm sort of running a business where we
put systems in we spent time to make
sure there's flexibility in that for
myself the sex ability in it for the
team that work with me as well yeah to
make sure they can you know do things
that they want to want to jump in and do
and i thought actually awesome
opportunity to come and say hi that's
great and it's really also for me it's
like again it's for me it's i don't even
see my 100 days of gratitude i do on
social media
but it's just about saying thank you if
you start every day by saying thank you
for what you've got you'll find more of
that to say thank you for absolutely
what you focus on expands
and your valid
your own you'll validate your own belief
yes so if you think like you said about
the recession oh in lockdown everyone's
struggling now if you think everyone's
struggling now because we're in lockdown
or everyone's struggling actually in
2008 crash
if you think everyone's struggling then
you'll struggle because you think that
everyone's struggling if you say
actually you know what most millionaires
get rich
in a crisis absolutely like you just
gotta always be positive um what does
your mama think now because you borrowed
the money off your folks to do the
academy yes which obviously has worked
pretty well for you good decision
absolutely 100 no i i knew it when uh
for me personally on that day it was
actually my first day full-time property
i'd spent six months researching
beforehand and once i had a day job and
i was like right
this is what i'm going to do 100 and i
just really came in the academy to meet
the controversial samuel leads to uh to
see what it was all about and you would
be a high energy event and then when you
said the academy and the opportunity to
network with more like-minded
individuals and learn all everything i
learned there was just like me it was a
no-brainer i remember being on the phone
to my dad being like right please i just
want to
please let me let me get involved with
this um
uh but yeah but there was there was a
lot of forethought to that and i'd and
i've i've done like you know five six
different businesses before then which i
had some summer work some had failed um
but then i was like right okay how can i
really sort of you know how can i make
the best of my communication with other
people and building relationships i
thought property would be the way it's
great to be focusing because i think a
lot of a lot of the reason people fail
is because they're almost one trip a
nurse and they try everything they've
got a bit of this their amazon
dropshipping and they're this and then
this it was so funny i i met sort of a
guy on the academy seb awesome dude and
we were he was he was so kind like he
was saying alex can you come view some
properties with me down in portsmouth
and i was doing that and literally just
before lockdown happened i thought it
was great but i was always very clear i
said service accommodation service
combination that's what i want to do
that's my key focus if this comes off
that's great but if it doesn't i'm not
worried because i've got my key my
keyframes so you were not only focused
on property you're focused on a
particular niche of property because why
you become an expert in service
accommodation so
but i think focusing is really important
um are you folks proud of you
yes they are yeah
they are good yeah we're proud of you as
well and i'm just great to to continue
relationship with you and to see you
winning and um you know super super
impressive stuff what do you think the
future of service accommodation is
that's it's exciting i think the the key
thing people got to be aware of that
it's um it's a market that's going to be
regulated that will happen in the coming
years so it's really important to keep a
really high standard of property yeah
i'm not exactly sure how that regulation
is going to come in on whether it will
be through
property sizes or limitations or whatnot
but keeping a really high standard
property is really important keeping the
relationships with the landlords and
relations with your guests are super
important because that as change comes
it'll be easier to affect that change
when you've got good relationships with
people
and i think she's going to build you
know people people
are expecting a high level every single
year we've got more access to
information on the internet every single
year we've although we've had some
freedoms taken away through coronavirus
we should be having more freedom
hopefully going forward
people expect more um and i think you've
got as a business and i'm sure you agree
like you've got to keep on giving more
value you've got to keep on offering
more as you're at the bottom line
which then leads on to sort of the other
products in your range yeah absolutely
so important and thank you for not only
adding value to your landlords and
adding value to your guest but also for
adding value to my subscribers it's an
absolutely incredible interview guys if
you found this helpful and useful please
do us a favor and let us know by
smashing the like button we want to see
the thumb pointing up so let's go and
hit that also if you've got questions
around service accommodation drop a
comment below i'm sure alexander will be
looking at the comments and we'll be
answering away so if you've got
questions about service accommodation go
ahead and let me know in the comment box
if you'd like to join me at one of my
training courses where you can learn
about rent to rent and about the
strategies about service accommodation
how it works i am running the rent to
rent revolution which is a completely
free training program and if you want to
come down on that on the house and then
all the strategies it all started um for
alex alexander at the at the free at the
free training and he went on to do the
academy if you want to experience the
same training that alex did for free
i'll leave a link in the description
check it out if you want to see more
videos like this i've got over 100
interviews that i've done with my
success students you can check a whole
place right here don't forget to
subscribe to the channel over here and
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time